finish being gel just because you know
like you don't like his take on women no
I don't okay I don't think he should be
a joke because he doesn't like women I
think that he should be in jail because
whatever he did he's obviously there for
a purpose and I did he get out earlier
than you're supposed to so they held him
without a trial at all so he had no fair
trial and they had no evidence they just
held him while they tried to build a
case and they couldn't find any evidence
so they let him go they've been doing
this for a year now okay
in that case then maybe he shouldn't be
in jail I still don't like Andrew Tate
though but maybe he shouldn't be okay so
we've done a whole 360. yeah we've done
a 360.